- I know nobody believes
me when I say this,
but I was actually pretty
shy when I was little
and then once I started getting on stage
and singing and kind of finding
that I felt like I was good at something,
it empowered me and gave
me like such a different
level of confidence.
- Yeah.
- So that's what, do you feel like that?
Do you feel like in life,
like art has kind of
- [Adam] Yeah.
- helped you become
who you are and were meant to be?
- Absolutely.
Even if it's many things,
once you kind of find what you love
it gives you a sense of self, you know?
And I, you know, and I love,
you know, like, like shoes.
I love shoes for, for,
you know, for example.
- [Kelly] Wait.
- Shoes really
keep me on track.
- Wait, I love shoes too.
Wait, this is not a, this is a real thing.
I love shoes, but I'm talking like, Nikes
like I have like so
many Nikes in my closet.
Like I, or what kind of
shoes are you referring to?
- Well, I like really
like the most extreme
as I can possibly find,
but also, I'm you know--
- We are so opposite.
- I'm gonna be turning
40 in a year and a half
and sneakers are becoming a necessity,
but I found these the other day online
and order them and I
wanted to show them to you.
(gasping)
- Oh my God.
No, but see, this is what's fabulous
about what you're holding.
Okay, see, I'm down
with what you're holding
and this is why.
See, it looks like a huge
heel, but it's the platform,
your foot's not actually
doing this the entire time, Jimmy Choo.
- They're, I mean, they hurt.
(laughing)
- They do?
Nah, then I won't wear 'em.
- Yeah, they hurt.
- Nope.
I'm getting too old for this thing now.
I'm just, I look at
myself and I'm like, no.
(laughing)
But, they look fabulous.
- I think they're like a moment for like,
like, like one performance or something
where it's one song.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Maybe seated on a stool.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
(laughing)
Exactly.
- Maybe.
- I love it, I love it.